in this video I'll break down the
recently released preview for the third
episode previous starts with a nurse
Targaryen on the walls of Dragonstone
most likely waiting for Jon Snow to join
her as it's been expected upon receiving
the nurses annotation along with Sam's
letter in which he stays that there's
plenty of dragonglass on Dragonstone
island the king in the north
left Winterfell for Dragonstone in order
to try to persuade the mother of dragons
to send her army send dragons north and
in order to collect as much revenue as
he can Jon Snow and our sea birth a
company that a few soldiers are heading
to white Harbor the main seaport of the
north
wherefrom they will set sail for
Dragonstone the king in the north and
Davos will arrive at the shores of
Dragonstone in the very beginning of the
upcoming episode air upon they will be
escorted by Tyrion and miss sandy into
the castle or more accurately in the
Dragonstone throne room to meet Daenerys
welcoming the near so the man from the
king in the north
to bend the knee John will try to
convince her that the real threat is not
Cersei but rather the night king and his
army there are also few shots of your
age arriving at King's Landing and
parading with his prisoners through
streets all the way to the red keep -
once again propose an alliance
accompanied with a marriage to Cersei to
pledge his arm in his arm flee to her
cause at this time Cersei will not
refuse upon successful defeating his
nieces forces you will bring captured
your a great girl arias and her daughter
tane to the capital as a gift for Cersei
which should Azure on set himself broke
his honest intentions leading to an
alliance accompanied with a marriage
between the king of the Iron Islands and
the Queen of the Seven Kingdoms
let's continue with a shot of Jamie
Lannister most likely entering the
Tyrell stronghold Highgarden upon
defeating Tyrells forces even though it
has not been officially confirmed Cersei
made an alliance with a powerful vessel
House of house Tyrell in order to
overthrow lady Elena and once they do so
that same vessel house will become the
great house and will rule over the reach
therefore Cersei will ensure the
provision of a food to the capital which
is of the great importance in a time of
war while just as I said in one of my
previous videos for his betrayal over
Lana Tyrell randyll will be appointed as
the new Lord paramount of the rich and
warden of the South in that video I also
introduced with a high possibility of
lady Elena's death that should take
place shortly after the fall of
Highgarden
so if you would like to hear more
details about the complete fall of house
Tyrell feel free to check out my
recently published videos beside a shot
of Sansa Stark walking through the
godswood of Winterfell which is most
likely taking place upon reuniting with
her brother bran there are also quite a
few shots of the unsullied invading the
ancestral stronghold of House Lannister
and the last episode Tyrion said that
great warm in the unsullied will sail to
Casterly Rock and pretty confidently
highlighted that they will take it so
those shots of the unsullied battling
Lannister soldiers is not surprising if
you're wondering how historians are sure
that the unsullied will manage to
conquer one of the most formidable and
well defended castles in all of Westeros
it's actually pretty simple so let me
just put it this way Tyrion will play
major role in the unsullied invasion of
Casterly Rock
while the Lannister stronghold is well
defended castle it will not matter
because Tyrion will show a sacred
passage to a small group of the
unsullied led by their leader reformed
into Casterly Rock through the sewers of
the rock for all of you that are
wondering how do you know about the
sacred passage through the sewers
well when Tyrion became a man at the age
of 16 he was given charge of all the
sewers of Casterly Rock by his father
Timon long story short Tyrion will most
likely show secret passage to great form
and his small team and once they stink
in the Lancer stronghold they will open
the gates for the rest of the in solid
whereupon they will easily defeat the
Lannisters forces and conquer Casterly
Rock in the following days you can
expect numerous theories and predictions
for the upcoming episodes